command the Seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest free to
play combat game world of warships
download now hey guys today it is the
29th of September my name is Jess and he
is what matters in gaming today a teaser
trailer full Sega's upcoming action game
Yakuza 6 has emerged onto the internet
the video was first shown at the Sega
booth during tokyo game show but is now
available for all to see the teaser
features veteran Japanese comedian actor
and director Takeshi Kitano who directed
and starred in several Yakuza films in
the 90s and is now confirmed to play a
character in the game Yakuza 6 is due
out in the fall 2016 full Japan although
no Western release date has been
announced as yet now cuz the 5 is
releasing digitally on PlayStation 3 in
the US involve this year rare have shown
off a conquer game that you are
unfortunately probably never going to
get your hands on the cancelled game
entitled conquer gettin medieval was to
be an online-only multiplayer game the
original Xbox in a video retrospective
Bad Fur Day director Chris fever
explained my interest was in multiplayer
that's where I saw the best scope for me
as a designer to do something new and
you to stay I wanted to take that idea
and just do a game like that where it
was completely online it was a bunch of
levels that change and you could come in
with your mates and fight with other
people the main focus of the game was
going to be siege warfare with conquer
relegated to a guest appearance in other
conquer news sandbox creation game
project spark has gone completely free
as opposed to free-to-play which
unfortunately means that future conquer
DLC has been cancelled microsoft
announced that while all content
currently in the game will now be
available to all users they are no
longer going to be releasing deal see
the update will also double world sighs
and prop limits so Microsoft are hoping
that you use
we'll pick up the slack in the custom
content department finally a Witcher 3
patch is on its way to address ps4
performance issues among other things
set up react announced that the upcoming
one point 09 hatch will include a
massive number of changes including a
range of bug fixes and a solution for
sub optimal performance on ps4 community
manager marcin melodic Slade was just
looking at the change log and it looks
really impressive the list of changes is
massive the update will bring a lot of
fixes and improvements including tips
for performance and well as other
platforms plus many more a release date
for the patch has not been announced at
this stage let me know down in the
comments what you cared about today and
be sure to head to gamespot well we've
got news on a hitman release date and
Xbox Live sign-in issues that's
everything I have for you today but do
you remember to come by same time
tomorrow for a bunch more news